Ok. So, it's $37.08.
Paper or plastic?
Plastic.
That's the magic word.
Green Police.
You picked the wrong day to mess with the ecosystem, plastic boy.
Battery!
Battery.
Let's go, take the house. Come on!
Put the rind down, sir!
That's a compost infraction.
Whoa! Did you install these bulbs?
Yeah.
Tragedy strikes tonight...
...where a man has just been arrested for possession of an incandescent light bulb.
What do you guys think about plastic bottles now?
The water setting is at 105.
We've got a TDI here.
Clean diesel.
You're good to go, sir!
Good afternoon, officers!
Are those foam cups you're drinking from?
Yeah?
Can you please step out of the car and put them on the hood?